que dans la suite des questions nous
allons continuer à en parler mais je
veux rappeler les chiffres de
l'e-commerce
il y actuellement une psychose française
sur amazon qui n'a pas beaucoup de sens
le e-commerce c'est 10% du commerce en
france amazon c'est 20% du e-commerce en
france y'a pas un pays européen où
amazon et plus bas qu'en france quand
les français augmentent leurs achats de
e-commerce à 60%
ça vient dans les poches du commerçant
français d'entrepreneurs français de
salariés français d'entrepôts français
comme cdiscount chez la sénatrice
harribey ces deux mille emplois et grâce
au confinement grâce au click and
collect c'est plus d'emplois en france
plus d'entrepôt en france et plus de
salariés en france et donc la psychose
française sur amazon n'a absolument
aucun sens
aucun sens amazon devrait-il doubler sa
part de marché s'attaquent 4% et donc le
fond du sujet sur lequel nous devons
travailler et avec lequel nous
travaillons avec les collectivités
territoriales je rappelle que la banque
des territoires finances pour chaque
mairie vingt mille euros pour faire des
places de marché local c'est de
numériser les petits commerces
il y à 30% des petits commerces qui sont
numérisés en france 72 % en allemagne
c'est ça le fond du problème
[Musique]